so I everyone my name is Bernhard where
I am from PI D to Budapest community and
I'm here to extend the kind and short
invitation to this year's Budapest bi
conference because we have a pied it
attracted Budapest bi going on for years
where we are discussing all things
related to PI data from data engineering
to machine learning and data
visualization our CFP is now open so we
are inviting everybody to submit a talk
there and there's a few thing which
would be good to know about PI data Bob
de peche bi for me this is not just PI
data it's a multitrack conference where
we are also doing tracks on our and
machine learning and data visualization
so it's kind of a good opportunity to
have a look into other array of data
analytics behind PI data there is some
fun things as well like we are doing
database challenge every year and
conference you can play and interact
with the best submissions we have things
like the GDP our air shark which is a
very good thing for people who are whose
work is affected by the GDP are like
mine for example and of course there is
social activities where you can where
you can try the local foods and if you
love your speakers there we do have a
quote for famous speakers and we do many
thing try to encourage diversity by the
way think it's important so a final
thing the Budapest is actually a good
place I believe who has been there
already
did you like yeah thank you
you know we have caustic or attack sure
we have our famous rareness pass we had
our even most famous rue in pubs and we
even have geeky things like European
Europe largest pimple exhibition
thank you very much so if you're
interested check out our PI data page or
consider submitting the talk to the CFP
or just reach out to me for any
questions and I hope to see it with a
pasty November thank you hello everyone
I'm Agatha some obscure and I will be
talking about radical engineers so we
are at the moment facing rising
inequalities global warming we are in a
threat of mass extinction so when we
need to do we need to radically rethink
our solutions and radically rethink the
economic and social system that produces
those symptoms the organization I'm
talking about radical engineers its
mission is to connect radical organs
radical organizations working on those
working on those issues working on
bringing post-apocalyptic
important distinction both capitalist
economies and bringing them together
with community of software developers
data scientists and designers we have we
have organizations that know the
solutions to these problems but often
they lack the expertise and
technological knowledge to bring them
about so one of the organizations that
we are working with is called ethical
dotnet it's an organization that
provides ethical alternatives to many
services that we use daily such as
messaging email web hosting analytical
tools and they need a data scientist to
help them with optimization of their
content through a B testing what can
radical engineers do for you well it's a
great community full of interesting
people think errors out of the box so
it's very welcoming community where you
can find people alike like yourselves
and you can find great meaningful
projects that you can contribute to and
build your portfolio we have a meeting
that happens on first and third Tuesday
of the week in shortage want to learn
more interested please do get in touch
we have a website Twitter Facebook email
there's really no excuse not to get in
touch as I was saying we have radical
Tuesdays twice a month the next one is
this Tuesday please do come along it
will be happening in Shoreditch in new
speak house that you can find as well
using this Twitter account thank you
very much
[Applause]
or time series forecasting which we have
been developing reintroduction name is
Pedro I work at the sky I deal with
network planning I work with a lot of
data and every now and then have to
forecast it so this is a library which
we have implemented in Python for
dealing with timeseriesforecasting focus
has been on beam easy to use it has a
straightforward API it takes
it's very tolerant in the kind of data
it can take and it just works on their
default settings so there is that it's
also a good deal of flexibility in how
you can configure your models and how
you can configure the things you can do
so using it is a one-liner you pass it a
data frame with your data and get back a
data frame with the forecast as well as
some additional parameters if you choose
to have multiple time series in the same
data frame it handles it just fine
there is also some built-in plotting
using plotly so you can have interactive
visualizations as for the inner workings
of this it's based on regression we have
system for composing model functions
from basic from basic functions which we
can use to pass a series of candidate
trends and series of candidate models
and have the system select the best fit
based on a metric which paralyzes model
complexity this is the set of basic
models which we usually use for the most
part it's linear trends which may be
adjusted for having piecewise linear
eating it also support for exponential
decay models and we support dummy
variables which can be
for example for applying events with
specific dates and there are several
types of seasonality including weekly
and monthly which work as well there is
possibility for users to define and
provider there are all models which can
be added to the basic set and it's
pretty straightforward just a lambda
functions will work forecast with looks
like and that's it
when we talk feel free to check out and
any kind of feedback or help would be
appreciated
thanks so much Julie that's my first
presentation outside companies so I'm
sorry I I work in Tokyo for a Japanese
company I'm 24 years old and I have a
master's in mathematics my friends
so step first just like study Japanese
learn Japanese if you want to work on
Japanese text because it's a it's a it's
a very beautiful language very concise
don't need compression because so much
information can be contained in like so
few words or you can just use a
dictionary I mean but don't trust Google
Translate I mean it it really causes
confusion sometimes if you do translate
for Japanese language don't ever write
business email using Google Translate
it's so like more like better ways to
like learn Japanese grammar which is
relatively easy as compared to other
grammars but the thing about Japanese is
like it has like the vocabulary it's
pretty big so you need to like remember
a lot memorize a lot so for that purpose
you couldn't just use the dictionary so
there is a very good dictionary
extension for Chrome so you can like
just hover over the text and and if you
have like some idea of grammar you can
just read the sentences and for offline
things just pretend that you can speak
Japanese there are some like YouTube
videos like which gives you like some
phrases so you can like and use those
phrases to like pretend that you can
speak Japanese well my coworker is here
she is okay
so I mean to read it pretty easily
beaucoup book 1 dice leaders it means
like I love Japanese language so in like
you can read it pretty easily if you
just know the grammar and just use this
dictionary tool just hover over and you
can easily understand Japanese step 2
tools for language processing in
Japanese so Japanese language don't have
any spaces like ice compared to like
most European languages to hear like
they are like separated by spaces so you
can easily tokenize them you like just
split at the word endings but like for
Japanese you need a tool to tokenize
them first
it's they have this tool for Japanese
called McCobb it's pretty easy to use
you can just see like it's developed by
Nara Institute and it's pretty easy it
does a pretty good job so cognizing so
for example like here there's a string
it means I love heightened and then it
can like tokenize it pretty and then
this is like a POS tagging as well so
you kind of like so you can like
tokenize and I give you the like
information like what is it it is it
like modern hound or like a particle or
objective or something or you can just
use sentence piece sentence piece like
this language-independent
and it can like work for mostly all
languages especially it's pretty handy
for Chinese as well next up is
canonicalization I mean in Japanese
these you can like write the same thing
using different different in different
ways Japanese they have like three main
scripts kanjis which are Chinese
characters and then here are gonna like
46 characters and then katakana which is
used to like write foreign words in
Japanese for example like for a soy
sauce
there are like in different ways you can
write soy sauce fun fact is like on our
database and bad it's like there are
like more than hundred variants of soy
sauce so like I mean people love like in
order to writing it in different ways
which like makes our job difficult you
know to standardize things and if you
have a like generator like text
generation model then yeah like you know
pool from thousand words meaning the
same also they had like half word then
forward variants as well so these
characters did they had they are like
also characters that like can be like
half word so which have like different
UTF code so it's a bit of a problem
you can like solve the canonicalization
problem using an encoder decoder model I
mean like hectare base encoder decoder
model so you just like like just choose
a text and the encoded and then decoded
accordingly and then use fast text for
representation the learning because it
enriches my first time speaking at high
data as well I've just come back from
two years in America on a Fulbright
scholarship learning the tools of
technology to study technology and how
it is impacting our society I'm along
the way I've met a number of wonderful
people but probably top of the list is
someone who's very familiar pi days and
s Bhargav Veda who I've been working
with I'm firstly going to present the
headlines of my research under the
advice of Professor Ben salt off and
then we're going to talk about a project
which spun off from my master's thesis
smartphone dependence this word can be
used to describe a situation where the
smartphone device is the primary device
that an individual has to access the
internet in the US now this is 15
percent of the population and I was
interesting research
you know who are these who is the
segment of society is this a new
vanguard of entrepreneurial people or is
this just a new way that a new digital
divide so to speak
so it was Python time around the machine
learning modules funnily enough you
might have noticed given that there are
14 percent of the population smartphone
dependent logistic regression is
actually the only model that actually
has higher accuracy than just predicting
that nobody is so if you wanted to try
and improve on some of these models
please do feel free to jump into the
code on github but running the logistic
regression what's really interesting is
that you know when with smartphone
ownership it's not that surprising to
see that education and income are
positively related but when we look at
this smartphone dependent variable the
the direction on those variable switches
which means that lower socioeconomic
status individuals are more likely to be
in this have this state of their
technology now you might be wondering
like why on earth does this matter does
this have any implications for the
future of these groups and and for
inequality proud to introduce bar graph
to say a minute hey so I think one of
the things that first kind of shocked me
was learning about attention engineers
which are just a bunch of people in
Silicon Valley who are literally
figuring out how gambling machines and
things like that work so they can
engineer our smartphones to get our
attention better
this thing's like batching Instagram
likes that you check it in certain times
and it just blew my mind there are
people like actively working on hacking
our brains and like like Lauren's just
talking about earlier how most of the
people who are using smartphones like
entirely dependent on only the
smartphone is their primary Internet
source happened to be from poor
socio-economic background which means
that they're more likely to get screwed
over by this kind of technology so I
think some of the cool work which
Lawrence is doing is trying to show
people that and also of course the
extension that there's a whole bunch of
researchers suggest that extensive
smartphone use and living on your
smartphone leads to increase anxiety
depression loneliness FOMO and a whole
bunch of generally horrible things which
we this is a whole bunch of research
would suggest that but people aren't
really taken in serious check on how bad
smartphone addiction is
and yeah so it's just something to think
about and I think Lawrence I'd like
Lawrence to share one last interesting
tidbit Thank You Bhargav it's been an
absolute pleasure to bring a Bhargav
into my spinoff project first week flip
phone this is a really practical way of
challenging people to rethink how they
are using technology and it is a
challenge to four seven days give up
this device to a friend to look after
and challenge yourself to instead use a
device that looks a little bit like this
the challenge is extended to everyone in
this room of course and I will the best
of luck with with your technology in the
future thank you okay so yeah my
lightning talk would be something about
pandas which is a lie because I think
somebody filled it in for me and I think
that what that person is mark actually
I'm talking about something about pip so
yeah this actually this lightning talk
is I need to thank Alex for that I think
I do believe maybe he already catched
the flight back to Germany but anyway um
yeah I hope we record it so he can see
it later because I like couple days ago
we met it you're a Python and I like you
kind of have this idea of like oh how do
we know that we like when you do a pip
install or languish cuz like you have to
install something so you can use and
then like after a while you'll be like
Oh what have I installed in my
environment so I can reproduce it on
binder or something and then you look at
like you can look at it by pip freeze
right but up list so what happened is
like it would give you all these
dependencies which is like oh my god
some of them is like I don't know what
they are but I just have it because I
used or something else so I tried so he
got these ideas like can we find out
which one or the one that I installed
actively so unfortunately we can't like
have a simple solution so I try to write
some code so I can figure it out
first of all because remember this like
pibblies I can have everything right so
basically I'm extracting this so I put
it like into you know you're processing
and then put it in base
this or packages will show you all the
list of packages that huh
so so for actually like I didn't know
that before in pip you can kind of pick
a packages and say pip show I will show
you the packages of like all these
information about it actually you're the
author of this package we're right on
the setup tool so if you have been to
the setup the package in unconference
then you know more about this one so
yeah so this six it's actually required
by the other packages that it's on your
environment so you know that this six
packages I didn't you know in store it
actively because maybe I install some of
those than it is to it for me so what I
can do is like I can catch all these
information it may take a while but yeah
so basically if you look at this thing
right this require poi is what this this
packages is required by the other
packages and requires that means that if
this one is requires all the
dependencies I will show here so yeah
this take a while that's why I do a
cache because I got a capture that like
more later so what I can do is I just
like pop all the packages and do like
pip show with all of them so now like
what I do here is like I take all of
these and then basically I'm checking
these ones if I split it do I have like
just require by with nothing or like or
I've more so I pick out this like four
pack just left that is like only um this
only required by it so it's like
required by nothing right for example
this ginger it's like showing me that is
required by nothing but wait a second I
never installed ginger to actually in
this I create a new environment for it
so basically in this environment I only
have chips and notebook that I was in
store and of course pip but yeah why why
that's like for I never installed injure
to and every store what does it call it
pop I dream it teaching me I don't know
how yeah Pickman so I don't have it so
ynyn so I think maybe because the the
capital of gin that like kind of mess it
up because if I show notebooks for
example then actually it requires in
questions are too right but it doesn't
but like but for a check it it doesn't
show here so I think there's something
wrong maybe with pip but before I can
send a pile to pip which I have to
understand how it works
I could do something like a workaround
which I checked you know the other like
the other way right I checked if any
requires that it's like half ginger in
it so at the end there's something wrong
oh okay it wasn't showing this before
okay I don't know why but um but yeah
it's supposed to be just doing two so I
have to fix it
sorry I don't know why it doesn't work
yeah dangers of life coding so that's it
so that's pips tree and then the message
I want to show here is like please use
empowerment control
don't rely on PIP and then you make some
like really crazy things like this which
you don't know what you have in store so
yeah you can use if you have been to the
packaging conference then you would know
that like we can create different
pressure empowerment to offer different
projects so yeah thank you well this is
PowerPoint clearly I'm not real many of
you know me I've done lightning talks
have another talk before on this
occasion I'm following the Evangelist
corner because the too long don't wanna
pay attention
a new report came out from the Royal
Society recently which I had a minor
hand in called the dynamics of data
science skills we're all very lucky
generally in this room we are highly in
demand across many if not all sectors
and what the Royal Society who I think
I'm right in saying date back to 1660 so
we may be a modern thing they definitely
aren't but they have latched on to the
fact that we have a skills problem there
are lots of tables there's loads of data
this was maybe a 20 page report it
turned into a hundred and three pages
with two appendices so it's not a light
read but I would encourage everybody to
go there's a link there or you can just
google for it
download it have a look it's about what
we as society and as a community need to
do to tackle many different things if we
want to have these skills and use these
skills and engage with the
future of society and how it interacts
with AI and how we can have a data
literate populace everybody loves a map
I was surprised that the growth in data
science related jobs in Northern Ireland
you would have thought it would all be
in London centric it actually isn't I
mean these are proportional growths part
of the key point in the report is about
the fact that you have an interface
between academia industry and the public
sector I'd also throw in charity third
sector in there as well but then I'm a
data kind pollen tier and there are a
lot of recommendations and the way they
kind of framed it is they looked for
good practical case studies in how
people are already trying to do this
within different communities and they're
there to inspire people to engage with
so things like developing skills in the
workforce there's how do you partner
between universities and employers how
do you develop data science into a
profession in a coherent setting how do
you enable what they call braided
careers where you can easily move
between different sectors what else do
we have we have enabling movement so
there's the braiding there's recognizing
diverse research outputs but trying to
get academics to potentially engage more
on commercialization there's also
widening access so this includes things
like data kind of doing pro bono work of
actually donating those skills talents
back out providing access to computing
power
if universities have got HP C's which
are Sat they're not doing anything maybe
you can engage and actually share that
so we're not just burning power for no
good reason
also encouraging good data practices and
beautifully there's you know dovetailing
on to the final key note there is
definitely a shout out to the problem we
have in a leaky pipeline and that
diversity is everybody's problem not
just the people who are underrepresented
so I highly recommend you get in have a
look look for places you can engage part
of my involvement is because I am
currently an entrepreneur in residence
and I'm advertising this out there
because the round is currently open for
applying for this it will end in
September if your employer will allow
you to have 20% off
to go and engage with a local university
for an entrepreneurial innovation style
project they can get up to 20% of your
salary paid but to them directly by the
Royal Society along with a travel budget
and everything else up to a max of 20k a
year for two years it's an experimental
program this is the last of the initial
three-year run so there's no guarantee
there will be any more of these after
September it's been a huge success I've
loved it I've engaged with other people
in other sectors it has me having all
sorts of conversations about interesting
things so if you want to know more find
me some of my contact Eaters are on
there thank you very much okay this is a
talk called Penner's not read fwf it's
based off of some independent work that
I've been doing relating to financial
data sets we're at PI D to London it's
Sunday July 14th 2019 I'm James Powell
if you're interested in this please
follow me on Twitter there's actually a
call to action at the very end so you're
using pandas and you might use read
f-type fwf to read a fixed-width file
and you pass it some data file and if
you look at the help of read FDF you can
see there's a couple of arguments the
star star key words and if you wonder
what those stars to our keywords are
they're more or less the options to read
CSV and so when you run into trouble
with read fwf you probably will just
look at some of these options randomly
pick one of them and see if that fixes
your problem because that's what we'll
see what people do with read CSV oh I
need a header let's see if there's in
there oh I need to parse the dates
correctly well unfortunately for the
particular file that I was dealing with
it was about a gigabyte in size and it'd
take me 60 seconds to process that
entire file and ten gigabytes of memory
to process a one gigabyte file so
behind-the-scenes pandas was doing a lot
of stuff that I didn't want it to do and
I was wasting an enormous amount of time
in fact if you really sit down and
wonder why is this so slow in pandas
it's pretty obvious one the pandas
operations are very safe and they're
very ignorant I don't have to know
anything about the data file I don't
have to know the format of anything
their panels will go and try and make a
lot of guesses about what the content of
that file are and provide it to me and
if I don't like those guesses I'll look
to that enormous Li long list of
arguments and figure out which of those
arguments tweaks pandas guessing
routines to just work it turns out that
I actually know a lot about this data
because the data I was looking at was
institutional data that a client
was paying a lot of money to have access
to and it came with a very thick manual
explicitly saying this is what the
columns are this is what's in it and if
that documentation was wrong that was a
contractual problem and so there was a
very good guarantee that if this is a
date column it's always gonna be dates
and a lot of this guessing that pandas
was doing was completely unnecessary and
so it turned out that in exploring some
of this problem on my in my own spare
time I found that there were speed ups
at every step of the way it's it's
amazing how trivial of a speed-up you
can find in pandas not allowing
functions for example this used an
enormous amount of memory and you're all
familiar with how certain operations in
pandas will have an in-place keyword
argument and sometimes you can pass in
false there to have the or true there to
have the operation performed in place so
a copy isn't done it turns out in
practices a little bit trickier to
actually manage because sometimes you're
not sure if behind the scenes some kind
of memory is being copied and so
actually controlling your memory use is
very difficult one of the reasons why
controlling memory use in this case is
important is this one one gigabyte that
one gigabyte data file was actually one
of three thousand files that we were
trying to simultaneously import and so
ideally the less memory that one reader
can use the more we can paralyze this
across all of the files and so the more
that we can have one machine actually
process so a very simple optimizations
that we can perform is instead of
reading this in two pandas what we'll do
is we'll read it into a numpy and dra
without making a copy so we'll take the
raw byte buffer tell numpy this is a
numpy ND array and then we use numpy
Recker a's in order to split up the
individual columns because it's a fixed
width file we can do that because we
know exactly where a column begins it
ends and then we could perform the
column transformations ourselves
directly now it turns out women
performing the column transformations
for a financial data set it's not
uncommon for that financial data set to
have asked you or iso-8859 - one encoded
data and I need to turn that into a
Python Unicode string which means I have
to do a decode operation which makes a
copy and is incredibly slow because
it'll do a linear scan of the entire
block of memory however it turns out
that with a little bit of site down what
you can do is you can grab from inside
Python the code that constructs a pipe a
Python string with the reference to the
underlying data set and you can just say
no no no don't decode it just assume
this is a Unicode string and that works
because ISO aa5 9-1 like ascii is
actually a strict subset of you
and so this works you don't even do the
decoding you just say you know what this
is actually unicode don't worry about it
it turns out even for integer and double
and pan is what would you do use your
pen is not to numeric or you do a 10 D
array as type and if you dig deep enough
you'll find this eventually calls within
Python PI OS string to double which is a
very safe routine that handles things
like exponentiation that handles
negative signs that handles extra
padding but you can write your own
trivial unsafe version I found that in
about an afternoon if I wrote a very
trivial like a comp Sai 101 unsafe
version of a to L or of a or an
equivalent for turning a string into a
floating-point number and I didn't
handle spaces because I know it's fixed
with I didn't handle exponentiation I
didn't handle negative values and I
handled fixed point values I'd get a 20
to 30 percent speed-up on just
converting a string to an integer
converting a string to a double now for
date fields you might use pen as that
date time which does an enormous amount
of guessing cuz sometimes it'll use date
util dot parser dot parse which is very
slow because it guesses it uses
something akin to a red X to guess what
the format is now there are some fast
paths within pandas for is no date times
but for this particular case it wasn't
right so date time it was a day time in
this particular format and it's not
uncommon for me to see things like this
which maybe represents monthly data or
quarterly data so it's not really a date
time it's some kind of interval or for
me to see some weird daytime format like
this like day month year or something
even more exposures like that some
Thomson Reuters take history data is
actually in this format where it's like
July written out - the date and then the
year and then you have to do some
mechanics and some copies to actually
parse it well you can pass in a format
argument - pen is not to date time and
that works but a better thing that you
could actually do is it turns out that
for a date time or a time there's only a
set number of finite values so it's much
faster significantly fast like 30%
faster to find all the unique values
parse the unique values first and then
map them back in fact it turns out that
what you want is a date/time 64 object
so you need to do some kind of object
construction to fit the data into the
format that you want and so if you have
a YY mmdd which is a byte string this is
8 bytes which means it fits into one
64-bit register you can play some tricks
so you can fit that into a one 64-bit
register use the first two values to do
two levels of lookup use the last value
by addressing that register differently
you can get exactly a a 16 byte or 8
byte integer you use that as an offset
into a strict array that has pre-cached
all of these values and you get some
significant speed ups now I didn't go
that far with this particular example
but it's a bit it's actually it's
actually surprisingly possible to do now
with just a couple of these very
simplistic approaches maybe an afternoon
or two of work I was able to take this
down to 10 seconds and one gigabyte
memory at 10 times memory improvement
and a 600% speed-up with very trivial
approaches and so I started to speak to
a couple of people about this problem
and I think that there's a need at least
within the financial sphere for an open
source unsafe readers package reading
fixed with files and CSV files
I've spoken to Travis Oliphant at Quon
site and Wes McKinney at Ursa Labs I
think there's an think you could start a
project like this specialize the
financial data sets and in fact there's
a thought as to whether you can actually
look for institutional funding because
this is something that could very much
improve any particular organization's
ability to process data there's a lot of
assumptions you can make for financial
data because for example the dates are
usually only from 1970 to today so
there's a lot of these little chip away
unsaved optimizations you can perform
and so if this is something you're
interested in please follow me on
Twitter or come and speak to me it's a
project I think would be very valuable
for at least one niche may be valuable
for other niches and I'd like to see if
we could try to maybe build an
open-source project directly with
institutional funding from people who
would benefit from it thank you so much
[Applause]
I'm a data scientist and I'm Moshe
brewer later you can tell me which one
should be my actual job and I'm also the
last person between some of you and the
pub so I thought you know should might
as well stay on topic anyway if you
don't like beer you can still enjoy this
talk because this is going to be about
over engineering on the other side if
you do like Vieira
my suggestion is that you know instead
of chugging one pint after the other
you kind of learn about beer learn about
stars
beer cultures how it's made what is
coming from and so on so let me walk you
through brewing first of all ingredients
you have four core ingredients water
malt hops and yeast
if you're German you're going to be
strict about this they have a purity law
and so on if you're Belgian you know
there is some creativity and then all
different beer cultures are equally
interesting
that's ingredients about the process
this is something you could do in your
kitchen
okay so machine means putting the model
together with the warm water kind of a
porridge you let them be for a for a
control in a controlled environment for
some time then you take the grains off
bring everything to boil add the herbs
cool it down to room temperature
understand in a few hours the in
fermentation will happen in a couple of
weeks and you're ready to go so there
was ingredients you have the process now
we need a recipe that's an example of a
recipe that's a complex one you have a
lot of things going on a lot of
different types of molds a lot of
different hops and different
temperatures different steps so it looks
complex but essentially Figgy if you're
a brewer and I give you this you should
be able to replicate the results and the
results turn out to be quite good as
some of you know this mine so I've been
doing this for a while and I feel quite
comfortable about coming up with my own
recipes but I still like to go online
and see what is going on what people are
working on there are a lot of online
forums where people share recipes ideas
techniques and whatnot so still look for
for inspiration these days and
essentially people in the brewing
community are very much open source if
you want open source oriented so people
who like who share their ideas online a
very nice and people who share their
ideas in a machine-readable format are
very very nice and now that I know that
I have a machine-readable format I want
to automate the process so I wrote a
script to download recipes in the XML
format and then to convert the recipes
into a tax form readable for me kind of
standardized so I run a script I let it
be for a while
then things got out of control and now I
have 80,000 recipes and I'm not going to
read 80,000 recipes because they are
80,000 so how can i aughtta mate the
process well if you want people to take
you seriously nowadays you have to talk
about neural networks and here we are
according to Vince enter the were not
enough talks about deep learning this
year so here we go so I brought some
neural networks near Network application
and then because I do an LP and when you
have a hammer everything must be a nail
I try to apply my NLP oriented neural
networks to the problem so I look into
recurrent neural networks for sequences
that's you know you know everything
about recurrent neural networks and in
particular I decided to dig deeper into
long short term memory lsdm so that's
the theory in practice we want to use
Python and you know tends to flop I
thought you have all those tools I just
chose scaris because I don't know any
better so kind of the first one that
came up I write a few lines of Python
not so sure now I have an AI that can
generate
beer recipes now sometimes it's good to
take a step back and there are some
questions that you may want to ask so
first of all is the beer any good well
not yet stay working on it are we taking
the fun out of the process yeah probably
so I guess for the time being I'm going
to stick to manual labor now some of you
have seen this talk already now the
reason I decided to give it again is
that I knew Leah was going to be here so
maybe we can ask nan focus to find the
20 20 why did a branded custom beer
[Music]
the end of the talk this also at the end
of the conference so apart from the beer
we can also think about you know what
you would like to see next year we've
been talking about diversity maybe we
would also like to see more diversity
both at the conference and in the
leadership so maybe here we can we can
think about it all together and in
general you can tell us how you enjoy
the conference what worked what didn't
and how we can improve experience for
everybody we're gonna wrap it up shortly
yeah closing notes
can I have my co-chair persons